you
hello everybody and welcome to part 15
of machine learning and penile
recognition for the use with stocks
forex automated trading algorithm
trading where we left off we were
playing a chart and it gave all the
predictions basically in the form of red
or green and also where they were on the
chart and now the next thing that we
need to do or we would like to do is
let's actually plot out the the actual
outcome right because we are going back
in data we ought we do have the
information to tell us what the true
outcome was so let's plot it so what we
want to do now is let's go up here to
our let's see pattern found and we give
off the colors here so really what we
want to do is just come down here right
before we start plotting the other stuff
and what we want to do is say real
outcome range and that that's going to
be equal to all data and then that all
data will be to what plus 20 to the to
what plus 30 mark but but don't forget
what we have done to ourselves because
if we scroll down we can see that ok
here's to what and but then we have no
wall data right because we would use
average line but average line is stuck
too to what
so what we can do is take just take this
right here average line and we'll just
make a variable called all data equals
that oops that was a cut my bad taste
that anyways uh make sure you didn't do
that so we want them both here but we're
just going to call this all data because
it is all data we want to look into the
future but this one only goes to right I
mean we start it off very nicely but
then we did this all right and we
redefined it to just be to what so what
we want to do now and really this is
probably a bad use of our memory
I think I think what we ought to do is
say let's comment this out and call this
all data awesome we're very smart guys
so that'll save us like I don't know how
much memory but it'll save us moving
around stuff help processing time
slightly anyways um now because this is
already in memory now what's the next
thing we want to do now that we've done
that we've got all data the next thing
that we want to do let's go back up here
kind of left it because we were had to
define that variable before we forgot so
now we've got all data and then it is -
what + 22 what plus 30 writes that range
so this is giving us a range of 20 to 30
in the future so kind of similar to how
we predicted the outcome of all the
other patterns in the past so we've got
that range now we need to reduce it
right do that that averaging with it and
I'm pretty sure we actually just have I
was thinking we could find one really
quickly and easily and before I like
zoomed over 1 or something
I just wanted to copy and paste it but
wow it's actually here we go
let's just just find one of these these
ones where we've already typed it out
for the most part and just copy it so
this was average outcome in our pattern
storage variable come back down to the
bottom the where we were working and now
what we'll do is real average or ABG
outcome equals paste and then copy this
variable here paste that over outcome
arrange paste that over the real outcome
range and now you have your average
outcome subsequently the next thing we
want to do is we have the average
outcome but keep in mind this is not a
thing how to put it I guess the easiest
way to do to say what I was going to say
is to show you the chart so just hold
off on that for now real movement is
going to equal percent change of what
well starting point is all data to what
right so that last bit of data and then
you've got your real average outcome so
we wanted a percent change since our
graph is a percent change chart but it's
a percent change of something of the
last point so just keep that in your
mind before anyways so that's real
movement so the last thing we need to do
is we want to actually plot that real
movement so let's do plot scatter and
just so it's not on top of everything
else we're going to put this at an X of
40 but again just like the other video
this isn't drawn to scale now because
like the actual patterns themselves are
being drawn to scale but as far as like
the predicted outcome and the future
outcome the real outcome and all this
stuff that we're going to plot it's not
so it shouldn't matter to you but just
in case someone is like hey what gives
anyway that's what's going on anyway I
just don't want to distort the chart
there's no reason to put it out that far
because it's just strictly visual
representation and it's like a
prediction kind of stuff but anyways so
X 40 Y real movement whatever that
percentage is color we want to color
this you know something very special so
will you just use the same color as that
line right that makes sense right so
where is the actual ending of this line
and there it is and sighs we'll give
this a really big dot of 25 cool so save
that run that and let's see again the
blue text above is from the previous
tutorial but this would be all fresh
text data laying that's coming out cool
I'm going to pause this while we wait
okay this is a pretty ugly chart but
that's okay well we'll continue forward
after this one so here's our lime based
on this one pattern that it's close to
this was the prediction
here's our outcome so I guess it was a
good prediction it underestimated it but
Direction wise it was correct so let's
close out of this one
in order to continue let's go to another
one there we go this one's a lot more
juicy so here we have pattern
recognition we can see that it appears
that there are more green than red but
upon further inspection and
it might be something else but it does
certainly look like there's slightly
more green than red sure enough it did
indeed go up but the real question is
you know what was the actual you know
what you know let's actually count these
dots right that's the idea is we
actually wouldn't mind finding out what
really is the prediction and to find out
really if this was indeed accurate or
not so the next thing we would want to
do is we want to kind of average in you
know you could average both the
intensity right this one's very the most
intense you know drop and this is
obviously the most intense rise and this
was reality but what we can do is just
is just say just compare red to green
you know what is the ratio between rise
and fall and let's just keep it simple
and do that for our prediction so that's
what we're going to be doing the next
video and we'll predict or we'll plot up
a prediction dot right to further decide
if we want to continue on and make a
full back tester or not so anyways
that's going to conclude video 15 as
always thanks for watching thanks for
the support in the subscriptions and
until next time